this episode of the Y files is brought
to you by
Factor during the 1960s and 7s the
United States and the Soviet Union
fought the Cold War on many fronts some
of these engagements were obvious like
the Cuban Missile Crisis and the proxy
wars in Asia other conflicts were not so
obvious in the 1970s America and Russia
engaged in a new type of warfare psychic
Warfare the CIA was actively recruiting
and training people with a natural
talent for remote viewing remote viewing
is projecting your Consciousness to
anywhere on Earth and Beyond one remote
viewer entirely by accident found
himself at Mount Hayes in Alaska Mount
Hayes is in the middle of nowhere
there's no civilization for miles but
something was calling him to the
mountain then he looked inside the
mountain there was a base hidden inside
mount Hayes then he saw this was not a
base built by humans when multiple
sources confirm the existence of the
base they soon realized this was only
the
[Music]
beginning yeah human I need help now
immediately pronto ASAP yesterday toot
sweet waa take it easy take a deep
breath and tell me what's going on okay
you know how I get Gertie a big surprise
for Christmas well you mentioned
something but you didn't say what it was
well we flew her parents in for a month
and a month what do you mean we F the
hang on hang on you are focusing on the
wrong part of the story ah but now that
you mention it the company credit card
might be a tad prodigious this month
prodigious it means huge I know what it
means by the way something can't be a
tad prodigious that's focus focus focus
we'll talk about this later what is the
problem well I'm trying to cook them all
dinner but everyone has different
requirements the parents don't eat
gluten dirty is doing keto why is she
doing keto oh she's upset with the size
of a hump okay no I don't mind a hump
that's a had prodigious that's not how
you use that word and the Beaver
Brothers are driving me nuts Wyatt is
only doing protein shakes now and
virally more than a pescatarian whatever
the hell that means my cooking skills
are not this diverse wait you don't know
what pescatarian means oh I assume it's
just some hippie nonsense well a
pescatarian whatever Webster I need
cooking help not a dictionary you really
want to look that word up are you off
your Ms again Focus okay look will you
just use Factor
Factor oh did you just wiggle your way
into today sponsor well yes yes I did
factor is a subscription meal service
that delivers pre-prepared meals to your
door they're fresh never Frozen and
ready to heat and eat in minutes yeah
but it's the food any good I don't want
it to be Bland or boring I'm known for
my uh gen Factor has registered
dietitians working with gour chefs they
do all the planning cooking and prep for
you they upload new menus every week
with over 30 35 meals and 33 add-on
options they have plans that range from
4 to 18 meals a week and you can add or
reduce as needed I'm actually a factor
customer I eat their meals every day at
the studio yeah but what about all these
special requests well they have meat
plant-based meals paleo keto and uh
seafood seafood yeah for pescatarians
wait do you mean and hellofresh now owns
Factor so I can switch between the two
Brands it's convenient and
easy
you still there hang on hang on I'm
Googling piscatarian y oh oh no go the
[Music]
humanity head to factor75.com or click
the link below and use code the yfiles
50 to get 50% off your first Factor box
factor75.com with code the yfiles 50 and
I get 50% off my first box that's right
no the humanity
okay you're a little over the top now
all right let me go I got to have a word
with the beavers and hang on what's that
honey just take your parents luggage
into the guest room that's where they're
stay in um we don't have a guest room
sure we do hang on hang on I can't carry
the bags I told you I threw up my back
playing pickle ball oh don't give me
that when we first met remember what you
did for a living you carried things okay
look I got to go deal with this wait
wait wait what what guest room the uh
the room with all the dresses and shoes
that's my my wife's closet hey beas I
know what pescatarian is you fairy
little sons
of uh so I'm looking at the cameras uh I
can explain I'm going to need to come
home Gertie's mom is trying on my heels
look I'm sure we can figure out she's
going to ruin my shoes they're not big
enough for a camel
[Music]
toe the story of the psychic competition
between the US and the Soviet Union is
like the chicken and the Egg some say
the CIA heard the Soviets had psychic
spies so they launched their own
programs in response others say the US
was first and the Soviets were
responding either way both superpowers
created well-funded super secret
programs focused on ESP or extra sensory
perception in other words psychic
Espionage a skilled remote viewer would
be the perfect spy they could go
anywhere see anything completely
undetected remote viewing means the end
of State Secrets really the end of all
secrets but remote viewing didn't start
out as a military intelligence project
it began as a research project in 1972
two scientists Hal put off and Russell
tar launched an ESP program at the
Stanford Research Institute or SRI then
they started looking for volunteers and
came across ingos Swan oh hey uh what do
you call a fat psychic please don't a
fortune
teller
H Ingo Swan claimed to be a great
psychic put off was skeptical so he set
up a test the team had access to a large
magnetometer which can detect slight
variations in magnetic fields Swan had
no idea what the machine was even though
it was buried under 30 ft of concrete he
could see into the device and describe
it he was able to sketch the
magnetometer readings then he was able
to affect the readings this was good and
bad good that Ingo proved his abilities
but the purpose of the magnetometer was
to detect Soviet nuclear tests affecting
the output set off alarms all over the
lab the experiment almost got them
kicked out of Stanford but the
experiment caught the attention of the
CIA they didn't care that Ingo could
move the needle but the fact that he
could see through superconducting
shielding buried in 30 ft of concrete
well that was a problem but also an
opportunity the CIA quietly funded sri's
research and had them Focus specifically
on remote viewing and Ino Swan became
known as the father of this technique
initial experiments were mostly
successful Ingo could identify images
and seal envelopes he could project his
Consciousness to different places and
see hidden objects but this didn't help
the CIA they needed him to view specific
locations Soviet locations so ingos Swan
and the SRI team created the scan 8
protocol project scan 8 was remote
viewing by coordinates
here's how it works you give a remote
viewer longitude and latitude
coordinates and you tell them nothing
else ingos Swan could see what was at a
given set of coordinates with remarkable
accuracy by the way ingos Swan also
remote viewed the moon I did an entire
episode on it it's linked down below now
I don't want to spoil it but what he saw
on the moon was pretty amazing and for
the record he's the only person who went
to the moon not
now soon another psychic joined the
project Pat price Pat was a retired
police commissioner he was a good
counterpart to Ingo Swan Ingo was a
painter he was the typical free spirit
artist he was loud and confident and
funny Pat price on the other hand was
grounded and serious Pat solved a few
crimes using his psychic abilities now
at the time pat thought it was nothing
more than intuition hunches that usually
turned out to be true after he retired
from the police department and had more
time to focus he realized his talent was
was more than intuition today Pat price
is considered one of the most gifted
psychics ever the CIA wanted to test
them both Pat and Ingo were given
coordinates to view nobody knew what was
at the site except the one CIA analyst
who gave them the numbers even though
they remote viewed separately both Ingo
and Pat sketched similar results they
saw the layout of some kind of compound
they said it looked high-tech they
described a large radar dish a
guardhouse they they saw roll up doors
and jeeps they said it looked like a
military installation Pat price was even
able to read documents on the site now
this is unheard of nobody else can do
this but Pat saw a cabinet labeled
operation pool inside were green folders
named Q ball 14 ball eightball and rack
up the team showed the results to the
analyst and asked how close they were
the analyst said sorry but these
sketches are nonsense I gave you the
coordinates to my cabin in West Virginia
the whole team at SRI was disappointed
and Confused how could both men be so
wrong yet see similar things so they
sent someone to the coordinates he found
the cabin but a few hundred ft down the
road from the cabin he found something
[Music]
else Ingo Swan and Pat price were given
the coordinates of a CIA analyst
vacation home in Sugar Grove West
Virginia but when they remote view the
location that's not what they saw they
saw a military installation the CIA
analyst who gave the coordinates didn't
realize that an NSA lising post was just
over the ridge from his cabin patle both
assumed this was the target this was the
type of location they were usually asked
to view the Sugar Grove facility in West
Virginia was one of the most secret NSA
installations in the country it captured
information from Soviet Satellites as
they flew over it served as a listening
post for all kinds of of transmissions
in fact Sugar Grove is in the nrqz the
national radio quiet Zone the nrqz
covers about 13,000 square miles in
Virginia West Virginia and Maryland no
radio signals of any kind are permitted
there if you fire up a radio you will
get a visit a fine and possibly jail
time a part of the zone is so locked
down that microwave ovens and Wi-Fi are
not permitted I no microwaves then how
can you enjoy a fresh delicious meal
from facta go to facta use promo please
don't plug them now what they didn't pay
for a mid roll no okay never mind so Pat
price and inos Swan got it right they
described this facility in detail from
Northern California 3,000 Mi away and
you think this would be caused for
celebration it wasn't every federal law
enforcement agency in the country showed
up at SRI they wanted to know why some
wacky CIA psychic contractors were
spying on an NSA facility and by by the
way project qall project 8Ball and rack
up these were so highly classified that
even the project names were top secret
the NSA was Furious once all the
agencies calmed down SRI went back to
work this time the CIA would focus on
the enemy who the American people the
Soviets
ah Pat price was given coordinates to
view he said he saw a science fiction
fantasy crane nobody knew what he was
talking about Pat grabbed a ruler pen
and in paper and Drew a Gantry crane
this type of crane is used to move
shipping containers and lift ships out
of the water they're big Pat said this
was the most giant crane he'd ever seen
he saw someone walk by and the wheels on
the crane were 10 ft High and the wheels
were on train tracks the CIA had a
sketch based on aerial photographs of
the site there was a giant Gantry
crane inside the facility Pat saw
enormous steel spheres 60 ft across Ross
there were no photographs of this nobody
thought much of it Pat said that
whatever they were building the Soviets
couldn't get it to work but 5 years
later us intelligence would discover
that the Spheres were there they were
nuclear containment devices and they
never work correctly Pat price was right
again at this point CIA plucked Pat out
of Sri they wanted him to work for them
directly Pat was given more coordinates
for a sight in Russia he tried to go
there but something was pulling his
Focus from his Target something in
Alaska it was a mountain Mount Hayes now
this was unexpected Mount Hayes is
desolate and
remote there are no roads and no
civilization for miles it's in the
middle of a frozen Wasteland Pat said he
didn't see anything oh he lied yes but
later on his own he projected back to
the mountain then Pat projected into the
mountain then he understood why he was
drawn there inside mount Hayes was a
huge base he saw advanced technology and
Equipment he saw computers and consoles
and machines that he didn't understand
then he saw the operators of the
machines Pat saw beings that looked
Almost Human but were thin with large
heads and they were busy at work on
something though Pat price didn't know
what then Pat got
scared
inside the mountain in the base working
alongside aliens were humans
specifically US military personnel 2
days later Pat was in Las Vegas as he
walked through his hotel lobby someone
bumped into him then Pat felt a sharp
pain in his leg the next day Pat had
severe stomach cramps and later that
evening he was found dead in his hotel
room his body was quickly removed no
autopsy was performed no crime scene was
designated the official cause of death
was a heart attack he was 56 years old
oh how did they know the cause of death
without an autopsy good question and
we'll never know Pat's body was cremated
and then they called his wife oh no his
remains are now in an unmarked grave in
North Hollywood we
think and I'm going to see what this
is this is marker
700 so indeed indeed P grave is entirely
unmarked I I think he deserves better
than that Pat was with the CIA for less
than 4 months a few years later the
cia's remote viewing program was called
project Grill flame same Mission
different name eventually it would be
called project
Stargate in 1980 the operations and
training officer for the project was
skip Atwater skip was a retired army
intelligence officer now recruiting and
training remote viewers one day how put
off shows up at Skip's door with four
files from Pat Price's remote viewing
sessions each with a different location
Pat gave the documents to Hal before
going to work for the CIA full-time Hal
told skip you might want to look at
these skip looked at the files and
couldn't believe it one location was a
secret alien base under mount hay Alaska
and the three other locations three
other mountains and three more alien
bases
you've heard of the Bermuda Triangle if
you follow this channel for a while you
know about the Nevada triangle these are
places where planes ships and people
vanish Without a Trace there are
mysterious triangles all over the world
there's the Dragon Triangle in Japan the
Formosa triangle in Taiwan and quite a
few others there's also the Alaska
triangle the points are Juno in the East
Anchorage in the west then up to Barrow
in the North since 1988 16,000 people
have gone missing in the Alaska
triangle Nationwide each state has an
average of about 7 people per 100,000
reported missing every year
Massachusetts has the lowest number
about two people per 100,000 Hawaii has
the second most 16 people not only does
Alaska report the most missing people
per year but their number is more than
10 times higher than Hawaii over 173
people missing per 100,000
and most of those go missing in the
Alaska
triangle the area is Harsh and desolate
I'm sure many of the missing people
simply succumb to the elements but not
all the people there are native legends
that go back thousands of years that
describe creatures appearing and
disappearing in thin air sometimes
taking victims with
them there's also something very strange
about the geology in Alaska it's covered
with negative magnetic anomalies this is
where magnetism operates in Reverse this
would be a nightmare for airplanes GPS
or any guidance system and the epicenter
of the Alaska triangle the place where
magnetism goes crazy Mount Hayes Mount
Hayes Mount mother Haze
okay Mount Haze is also a UFO Hotpot
spotted and tracked for about 24 hours
moving northeasterly at 40,000 ft at
that altitude officials say they did
fear this unknown object posed a risk to
civilian flights there have been
sightings of craft that go back years
and sightings as recently as a few weeks
ago people have seen objects hovering
over the mountain and then flying
information at impossible speeds the
reports of objects Vanishing into the
side of the mountain not through a door
through solid rock there's a theory that
the magnetic disturbances around Mount
Hayes are portals that allow spacecraft
to go in and out of the mountain Mount
Hayes was one of four mountains that Pat
price said contained a secret alien base
the others are Mount Puro in Spain mount
inyan gani in Zimbabwe and mount Zeal in
Australia Pat gave this information to
how put off put off then passed it along
to skip Atwater at this time skip worked
with another extremely talented remote
viewer Joseph mcmonagle I've talked
about him in a few different episodes
he's a legend in the remote viewing
Community he's conducted thousands of
remote viewing sessions for the Army CIA
he's also helped companies find oil and
precious metals he's helped law
enforcement find missing people if
anyone could confirm Pat Price's
findings it was Joseph mcmonagle so skip
gave Joe four sets of coordinates and
that's all no other information just the
numbers not only did Joe see the alien
bases he saw so much
more
it was July 28th 1982 project 8200
begins skip atwat dim the lights in the
interview room and took a seat Joe
mcmonagle sat on the other side of the
table pen and paper ready Joe had no
idea what he'd be viewing that's the
ideal protocol if a remote viewer is
given information about a location in
advance it could ruin the entire process
even small details can distract a remote
viewer details create expectations which
can lead to false positives for example
you can't say remote view this bowling
alley the remote viewer will start
seeing balls rolling and pins falling
beer drinking right I'm throwing rocks
tonight I got it are they really seeing
these things or is this just what they'd
expect to see at any bowling alley the
only way to be sure remote viewer sees
the correct location is by giving them
nothing skip had a map in a sealed
envelope he then read a series of
numbers coordinates 63° 39 minutes north
146° 45 minutes West Joe didn't know
what this was but skip knew it was in
Haze what so Joe relaxed closed his eyes
and projected his Consciousness to those
coordinates as images came into his mind
he sketched them on paper I have a bunch
of water land ice and all these these
General things written in here this is
generally a very desolate
area and I drew in the mountain
range I wrote mountains this is a whole
range of mountains that extends for
thousands of miles so that'll give you
an idea of the scale at which I'm
drawing here and I sort of put an X
where I perceive the target to
be going to the
Target and I believe that the target's
placed deep in this mountain range in
this desolate
area water land ice mountains a desolate
area Joe was describing Mount Hayes he
drew a pretty accurate map of the area
it was time for Joe to go inside the
mountain here's the target which is
perceptible the
tubes all
pipes masses of
electronics grid work of some
kind this is the Target which is
perceptible so the M of some
kind a sense of great
power uses a great deal of power
energy very low uh frequency
feeling this is the
target which is
describable huge
uh ground
grid forming
a electronic
Arena
see very large
power andp put lines from a miniaturized
nuclear power plant or power
unit other tubes buried in the ground
they're they're coil
tubes are
coils Joe said the things he was seeing
were so foreign to him that he had
trouble putting them into words he said
imagine an aborig trying to describe the
interior of a car they don't really have
any context they don't have words for
screws and bolts and Glass and Metal
that's how Joe felt the technology was
far beyond what he could comprehend but
Joe saw that the base was under a large
Dome on top of the Dome was an emitter
sending a huge amount of energy into
space next Joe is told the coordinates
of bount seal in Australia the
uh yawning entrance to a underground
cave black
doorway like a smooth Dome of
concrete the black
hole the sto site of some
kind I
see collage of things
buried
coils keep seeing boxes of
electronics under mount Zeal Joe sees
another facility with advanced
technology then he sees something
familiar keep envisioning uh control
centers keep can getting visions of all
the command and control centers I've
ever been
at Joe describes an underground Command
Center later other remote viewers would
describe consoles and screens and what
sounds a lot like
NORAD reference the caretaker Personnel
do you have visuals of them or no I just
perceive like a a watch doog course or
something there what uh kind of
emotional impact was this start oh it's
it's a very I have a very Sinister
feeling for this
target next Joe goes to mount Pito in
the panese mountains between France and
Spain the first thing he says is I see
sheep gray
rocks
sheet a natural cave cliff and
rocks Mount Puro does have Cliffs gray
rocks and yes there are sheep everywhere
Joe is the layout of the
facility this connection is
observable interconnecting points like a
spiderweb pression of
relay pressing that it catches something
and relays it back Dre high frequency
relay
transponder this is where we start to
learn that the facilities are connected
like a spiderweb go get
this impression of a string of beads in
the sky circling the
earth toward the end of the session Joe
could see the facility being built he
said the construction took place about 2
to 2 and 1/2 years ago oh he saw aliens
at the base nope it was being built by
[Music]
people when Joe mcmonagle was remote
viewing the site at Mount Puro Spain he
was extremely accurate he saw the cliffs
gray rocks and sheep that's the only
time he mentioned sheep in thousands of
remote viewing sessions but he was right
about them too when skip Atwater
conducted the interview Joe saw
something unexpected the facility being
built skip was expecting this to be
construction that happened hundreds or
thousands of years ago with advanced
technology maybe using UFOs but that's
not what Joe saw occupants are
describable helicopters
very rugged mountain range kind of
desolate vehicles of Transport are
perceptible
helicopters not large but small boxes
being brought in by
helicopters boxes being brought in by
helicopters so human involvement
military involvement this tracks with
what Pat price saw at the mount Hayes
facility he saw human milit Personnel
working alongside alien beings and just
like Mount Hayes Joe saw an emitter
sending energy into
space impression which I have labeled
receive I feel like this is situated in
a footprint in other words it's being
targeted with some kind of emitter and
that's a receiver I have a cable going
down into a Clift in the rocks on this
particular location and in the cliff in
the Rocks is a like a control black box
and a power
pack located in the center is a
small dish or disc type shape with a
spike in it and that's a very high
frequency emitter and it emits straight
up and that's there's a necessity that
this be located on extremely tall
Mountaintop or desert high range of
mountains during the session Joe also
gets the sense that this location is
also involved in transmitting and
receiving energy and
information the last Mountain viewed is
mount inani in
[Music]
Zimbabwe Joe sees a singular Mountain a
group of high hills there's a jungle
close by he sees black boxes of
electronics again he feels the concept
of command control and Communications
but everything comes together now these
command centers are linked Joe says it's
like like a
spider it's not turned on or it's turned
on but it's lying dormant they're all
lying dormant but they're all turned on
that are installed they're still going
in I get that impression it this is just
a gut feeling now but this is a
perception a con concept perception mhm
if you equate this to a
cobweb every single angle in the cobweb
represents a location on the cobweb and
I get in impression that the spider has
not turned his whole cop web on yet but
when he does then it'll just be rattled
the web
anywhere after the session Joe tried to
explain what he meant by spiderweb or
cobweb now remember Joe never mentions
aliens but he wasn't looking for aliens
he wasn't looking for anything he was
just given coordinates but he sees
technology he can't comprehend when he
views these
locations this is really this is this is
all off the- wall to me my raw
impressions are each one of these Target
sites is like a different spoke in a
wheel and that that's a bad example but
it's it's like it's like a diff
different part of a jigsaw puzzle and
each one is dormant it does nothing
unless it's commanded to do something
and then all it does is is
transfer it just transfers something I
get a just an overwhelming feeling of
the the big 3C you know command control
and
Communications what are these locations
transferring and to where Joe sees
it sensing and receiving and emitting
relay uh location is a integral part of
uh
location get a fixed uh fixed orable
platform it's not going anywhere no no
occupants now but there's a capability
see can't tell if it's occupiable there
or occupi before delivery it's fully
automated the occupant's fully
automated like every remote viewing
session after Joe brings his
Consciousness back he tries to explain
what he saw and what he wrote down skip
asks him to describe the space
platform and trying to go to the origin
of the spaceborn platform I got a very
old and a very New Sensation like like I
got both Sensations it's like uh periods
of time I'm talking about I'm trying to
quate the years and they're they're not
there's like I'm going from ancient to
new to Ultra Modern back to New you know
I'm flopping around in time so that
that's probably pretty important what
show means is that the technology is
extremely Advanced but but this space
platform has been there for a long time
ancient he says okay so where's the
platform this uh space born platform is
in is in a permanent fixed place it's
not rotating around the earth and it's
not uh it's like it's fasten with a
string to the Earth never moves and it's
way out there you know so it has no
decaying orbit it's
fixed and these bases aren't just within
the mountains they're also under the
ocean also there's more than just these
four
locations I have uh an immediate vision
of seabed locations you know I I
honestly believe that there are seabed
locations of these these things skip at
Water confirms this and all of these
sessions in a talk he gave in 2009 and
that's where he explains again
very old and that these have been here a
long time but what he is viewing is so
new he doesn't understand it there are
some of these on the
seabed uh they have to do with PR
precise
observation location and relay some
navigation use when Joe first viewed the
mount Hayes alien base he got a Sinister
feeling but as he viewed each location
that feeling became less and
less my initial part
or Target number one was I had a very
Sinister feeling Target number two got
less Sinister Target number three was
not Sinister at all this target has
convinced me that this has no absolutely
no evil content in the way that we would
describe evil skip Atwater had another
psychic who claimed to be in telepathic
communication with these beings in the
bases the psychic asked them what do you
think of humans the response was
basically not much uhoh yeah that
sounded ominous to the psychic too so he
asked the being to explain the response
was we see humans like you see a flock
of birds there are a few of us
interested in them scientifically but
most of the aliens on Earth while aware
of humans don't see us as anything more
than the other animals here yes we're
slightly more intelligent but otherwise
we're just animals in a zoo to them
animals with nuclear weapons right
there's that the only time ET will
involve themselves in our Affairs as if
we try to do something to harm the
planet how dare you notice I didn't say
harm ourselves the aliens don't care
whether we're here or not but they won't
let us hurt their Planet why not well
because the Earth provides them with
resources the four alien bases in the
mountains plus the bases in the ocean
are creating energy from something in
the Earth this energy is harnessed
concentrated and sent to an orbital
platform in deep space what happens from
there nobody knows Joe Monical's remote
viewing sessions were focused primarily
on Technology Energy and the space
platform Joe did see helicopters outside
the base at Mount Puro but he didn't see
the beings operating the bases but Pat
price did see them Pat price said the
bases contain beings that look like
humans except for the heart lungs blood
and eyes and if Pat price says creatures
are there they're there so skip atwat
brought in a few other remote viewers
not only to confirm the existence of the
bases
but also to see who is operating them
were they aliens or were they humans
according to several other remote
viewers the answer is
[Music]
yes when Hal put off gave Pat Price's
four files to skip Atwater at project
Stargate he told him you might want to
look at these Pat had seen bases inside
Mountains full of advanced technology
Pat saw aliens operating equipment and
in some cases he saw human military
personnel working alongside the aliens
remote viewer Joe mcmonagle confirmed
the existence of the bases and the
technology Joe even determined that the
bases are linked and transmit energy to
an object in space but he didn't see the
occupants years later ingos Swan trained
a few more remote viewers using CRV
coordinate remote viewing skip Outwater
decides it's time to go back to the
mountains remote viewer bill Ray has
given his first set of coordinates he
describes a hollow mountain in a cold
climate Mount mother Mount Haze yes
Mount
Hayes Bill sees electronic monitoring
equipment and metallic ships which are
very quick bill describes people who
were thin unemotional cold and acted
like they were programmed he felt like
they had a purpose and a mission to Bill
they felt unearthly remote viewer Paul
Smith saw a cluster of structures in a
cold wind swep s desolate area inside he
saw people manning the site they seemed
regimented and subdued he also saw
box-shaped electronics and cables
running
underground session after session skip
atwater's remote viewers saw the same
things some were more detailed than
others but all saw a mountain in a cold
climate all saw a base inside filled
with electronics and several remote
viewers saw thin unemotional beings
going about some kind of business but
ship was concerned that his own thoughts
might be bleeding into the sessions so
he conducted what he called a fully
blind session this is where not only
does the remote viewer have nothing but
the coordinates but the same goes for
the interviewer Ed Dames was the monitor
who read the coordinates to remote
viewer Mel
Riley Mel sees a structure within a
mountain he sees a dark figure seated at
a control panel operating a keyboard not
a keyboard like we use but something
with large buttons or Keys like a piano
Nano he sees other figures walking
around as Joe mcmonagle described Mel
says it looked like an underground
control center like NORAD at Cheyenne
Mountain and like Joe Mel also saw a
large Dome covering the structures then
Mel saw what he described as some sort
of UFO other remote viewers saw UFOs
also but skip Atwater later admitted
that they were afraid to put anything
about UFOs in an official report now if
we go all the way back to Pat price in
the 1970s he Drew what looks like a UFO
under one of the mountains in Skip's
lecture he sums up all the findings and
key
takeaways the price data itself
describes four locations which he
claimed and which was presupposed to be
UFO bases you know how did Pat do this
mean I don't know how he initially
targeted himself the sites were highly
protected from Discovery they were
mutually supportive in purpose and
they're very high technology of some
kind and the purpos of these spaces
included a monitoring
[Music]
function project 8200 confirms the
existence of four Subterranean sites and
several remote viewers saw or felt the
presence of
extraterrestrials project 8200 also
confirmed the sites are intentionally
hidden and working
together the sites are sometimes
occupied but not always they're used for
observation and relaying information and
energy to an object in deep space
finally Joe mcmonagle added that other
bases are located deep in the ocean
remember Joe is remote viewing in the80s
skip Atwater gave this lecture in 2009
that's long before the videos we've seen
of UFOs flying around and going in and
out of the ocean so after getting
confirmation of UFO bases that's when
skip Atwater decided he had enough his
project had limited resources and if
other agencies found out they were
spending so much time searching for UFOs
that could be the end of the project and
the end of many people's reputations but
something was nagging skip he kept
asking himself is any of this true well
he knew the CIA station Chief in
Northern Australia so decided to give
him a call he asked his friend in
Australia hey is anything unusual
happening down there the guy said nah
this is a dead assignment well except
for all the UFOs flying around Mount
[Music]
seal project Stargate was discontinued
in 1993 it was finally shut down because
according to the CIA it didn't provide
any useful information oh come on it a
kidding yeah that in itself is
suspicious the budgets for Stargate SRI
and psychic research were tiny compared
to other military and intelligence
operations the government spends more
money on office supplies than it was
giving to Stargate really it was shut
down because of negative PR remote
viewing and the US government's interest
in it was showing up in newspapers and
magazines and TV shows ESP was a very
Fringe idea I'm sure some senior
military official shut it down out of
embarrassment but while Stargate was
operational it kept busy Joe mcmonagle
and Russell tar both said that every
government agency was using their
psychics but nobody would admit it I bet
it's still going on I would think so
it's buried in a black budget somewhere
but how much of all of this is true well
a lot of it depends on your perspective
Ive and existing beliefs if you believe
in ESP then the story makes complete
sense if you don't believe the story
sounds Bonkers so let's see if we can
find the middle ground ingos Swan is the
most well-known remote viewer I've
covered him before and I'm a fan of his
he has some famous successes like he
said that juper had rings when he said
that it was a ridiculous claim later it
was discovered Jupiter does have rings
but he also said Jupiter had a huge
mountain range but on a gas giant that's
not possible hey did he ever a look at
Uranus yeah it's true that Ingo Swan got
plenty of things right but there's no
way to know what his true success rate
is very little can be verified but he
sure tells a hell of a story same with
Joe mcmonigle he's a legend he claims to
have a 95% success rate or 65% or 75% it
fluctuates Joe's done remote viewing
sessions for live TV and was successful
but his 15 minutes of footage was edited
down to 2 minutes of the best stuff
maybe it was edited for time and he had
15 straight minutes of winners I don't
know but it all started with Pat price
but there's not a lot of information out
there about him yeah and the CIA likes
it that way yeah Pat did die under
mysterious circumstances and the story
certainly sounds like a CIA hit but
years later a former KGB agent defected
from the Soviet Union and he claimed to
be an assassin and he said one of his
targets was a psychic in Las Vegas who
he poisoned
oh right if Pat price was really able to
see inside Soviet military installations
he would need to go but I can't find the
name of that Defector to verify the
story so CIA propaganda could be and
speaking of CIA propaganda we have to
examine the people involved in Project
Stargate very closely yeah we get a name
names yes we are
uhoh
since the 1970s a number of people with
very high security clearances have been
working on UFO phenoma they were
interacting with each other so much they
gave themselves code names the code
names were all birds so they called
themselves the Aviary cute well let's
start with the owl psychic research
begins with Harold how put off in the
early 1970s at SRI the Stanford Research
Institute we know that put off work with
the CIA on Project Stargate but the owl
has has worked on and off for the CIA
and the defense Intelligence Agency for
years but most of his work happened
after he left the church
of you bleep me well you know we can't
say the s word they they sue people fair
enough well how high did the ow get in
the uh uh CH uh church at Tom Cruz well
ot7 that was the top level at the time
yikes uh I mean I mean oh
congratulations what a nice achievement
hey I'm just giving information I'm not
making judgments I am put off is also
involved in UFOs he founded two the
Stars a private Venture investigating
UFOs also on the board of two the stars
is Christopher melon who's also former
CIA and Dia and Steve Justice former
director of advanced systems development
at lacky Martin and Luis elzando a
Former Intelligence officer who says he
ran atip atip or the advanced Aerospace
threat identification program
essentially continued Project Blue Book
elzando says he ran this program The
Pentagon says he had nothing to do with
it elzando says this is a smear campaign
Pop Quiz who do you believe an
intelligence officer or an intelligence
agency neither correct next Blue Jay Dr
kit green also worked on Stargate and he
was a CIA analyst in 2001 leaked emails
showed the Dr Green said the infamous
alien autopsy video was true it was well
it was a film produced in 1995 a hoax
later green said that he never said it
was real he said the still shot of the
face looked real so which is it next
bird falcon falcon is the infamous
Richard doie Dodie was a special agent
for the Air Force OSI the office of
special investigations he was in charge
of UFO disinformation programs one of
dod's assignments was to infiltrate the
UFO community and flood it with as much
disinformation as possible this way
people would know what to believe Bill
Moore a well-known UFO author destroyed
his career in a single
afternoon he publicly said he was taking
payments from the government via Dodie
and helping spread lies he was
essentially booed off the stage and we
haven't heard much from him
since but Dodie has since come forward
and said UFOs are real and that most of
the UFO stories we hear are real and
that's what is so disgusting and
troubling within the UFO committee
that's why I have nothing to do with
them anymore I've tried I've I've went
to UFO conventions and tried to explain
what the what the truth is and nobody
wants to hear you because they've
written a book that says it happened
this way and they're going to listen to
you even though they don't know really
don't know the truth is he telling the
truth now who
knows our next bird is woodpecker
woodpecker is Jamie shandera a film
producer he he's considered one of the
birds who wants UFO disclosure so there
are good guys and bad guys in the Aviary
but enter Bob Collins AKA Condor Bob
Collins is also a Former Intelligence
agent with OSI who engaged in UFO
disinformation campaigns in 1989 a
documentary was released called UFO
cover up live chandera was featured in
that documentary but this TV program got
people asking questions many in the UFO
Community consider the doc to be nothing
but a dis information campaign and it's
easy to see why Bob
Collins right he stated in his book that
after the documentary he attended what
he called a mini Summit this was a
meeting to deal with the Fallout of the
TV show at the summit was the AL how put
off Falcon Richard Dodie blue jay kit
green and Bill Moore who is being paid
by the government to lie to the public
about
UFOs according to Collins's Book quote
kit green took Center Stage by proposing
several lines of attack involving
disclosure strategies so are they on the
side of disclosure or
disinformation there's more you might
remember my episode on Project serpo
this was an exchange program between the
United States and aliens from the planet
serpo it's a great story and by the way
all these are linked below now it took a
long time but the planet serpo story was
found to be a hoax perpetrated by what
came to be known as the team of five two
of the five were Victor Martinez and
Bill Ryan who ran the website
disseminating the information the
information came from three men Al
Falcon and blue jay put off Dodie and
green once again Dodie later said serpo
is true and it may be but in telling the
story the team of five got caught
telling all kinds of other lies but some
of the lies they say are true I get into
all this in the episode and by the way
Bob Lazar and a few other whistleblowers
also say Sero is true so you make the
call but birds of a feather stick
together neither talk about it much but
for years doy aka the Falcon worked for
put off aka the owl Dodie spent 10 years
as a private contractor for put off's
company earthtech earthtech worked with
the US intelligence community on black
programs don't take my word for it
here's how the particular area that I
took responsibility for is based on this
there was a critical issue
as you can well imagine in these deep
black programs it's difficult for
contractors to obtain expert opinion on
critical Technologies because there's
such high level security and there
compartmentalization we call it stove
piping and so I was contracted to
commission papers from experts around
the globe and since we didn't want to be
in the position of going out and say hey
we're trying to figure out this UFO
thing uh you know can you help us out
here I mean the publicity associated
with that you our black program it would
have been a
disaster here's something else in 2006 a
book came out that blew the whistle on
everything it's called the black world
of UFOs exempt from disclosure it talks
about government coverups sensitive Dia
and CIA documents reverse engineering
alien spacecraft all the great UFO
stories are in this book I love it
what's what's the problem it was written
by Collins and Dodie Condor and Falcon
yep yeah look I believe UFOs exist and I
believe we have recovered craft but I'm
skeptical of anyone who's worked in
intelligence because once you're in
you're never out whatever is being said
about UFOs is by people like Dodie put
off alzando David grush I take all that
with a grain of salt these are not
whistleblowers these are people who
spent most of their careers in
intelligence the things they say they're
allowed to say they have permission
permission from who well well isn't that
the big question Pat price the psychic
who started it all comes off as the most
credible of all the people I talked
about today he was a retired cop from a
small town he used his gift to solve
crimes to help people and Pat was a
patriot the CIA asked for help and he
provided it 4 months later Pat was
dead in my research I found something
Pat price said that bothered me he said
this people have infiltrated all
government in sensitive positions not to
control government the processes or
people but rather to be in positions of
power to stop politically any activity
that may produce a result that could
cause Discovery Americans want
information about UFOs released Congress
tried and couldn't do it presidents have
tried and couldn't do it so if our
elected leaders aren't in charge who is
during Stargate it was discovered that
anyone can learn remote viewing some
people like Joe mcmonagle and Pat price
are naturally gifted but the rest of us
with practice and training it's a skill
we can all develop but that would mean
the end of all secrets that can't be
allowed to happen secrets are the source
of their power whoever they are and
that's why Stargate was shut down not
because it failed because it
[Applause]
[Music]
worked thank you so much for hanging out
with us today my name is AJ here's eckle
fish this has been the wi files if you
learned anything had fun do him a favor
subscribe comment like share that stuff
really helps us out and like every topic
we cover here today's is recommended by
you so if there's a story you'd like to
see or learn more about go to the W
files.com tips and remember the yfiles
is also a podcast twice a week I post
deep dives into the stories we cover
here in the channel I also post episodes
that wouldn't be allowed on the channel
it's called the yfiles operation podcast
and it's available everywhere you get
podcasts if you need more wi files in
your life cuz who doesn't you can never
get too much of this check out our
Discord there are thousands of people on
there 24/7 and they talk about the same
weird stuff that we do it's a great
Community it's a lot of fun and it's
free to join and if you want to stay up
toate with everything yfiles go to the
WI files.com
our production calendar is there you can
see what episodes are coming out what
podcasts when we're doing live streams
watch alongs all that stuff and special
thanks to our patrons who make all of
this happen every episode is dedicated
to you as you know there'd be no wi
files without your support I can't
believe you're here but I'm truly
grateful for you the best way to support
the channel is become a member on
patreon for as little as three bucks a
month you get access to perks like
videos early with no commercials access
to merch only available to Members Plus
you get two private live streams every
week just for you another great way to
support the channel is grab something
from the wifi store oh wait a minute
wait a minute I'm getting a vision a
vision a vision of you grabbing a Heckle
fish t-shirt or a fistal coffee mug or a
hoodie or a squeezy stuffed animal
Heckle fish Tu fish toy di go heck ofish
playing card game
cards that's going to do it until next
time be safe be kind and know that you
are
[Music]
appreciated
oh oh oh
yeah I play Bia scar 50 one a secret
code inside the Bible said I
was I love my UFOs and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing like
[Music]
I but then another conspiracy theory
becomes the truth my
friends and it's never
ends no it never
[Music]
ends I feel the crap cat I got stuck
inside M's hole with mkl Tru I being
only true
aware did Stanley curi fake the moon
landing alone on a film set with the
shadow people there
the r well aliens just fought the
smiling man I'm
told and his name was
cold I can't believe I'm dancing with
the
fish fish on Thursday night
J through the
night all I ever wanted was to just see
the truth so the W all through the night
[Music]
the MTH man sidings and the solar storm
still come to have got the the secret
City
Underground mysterious number station
Planet are to project State and what the
dark Watchers
found then a simulation don't you
wor the black KN satellite told me so I
can't believe I'm dancing with the
fish fish on thday night with they J
when all through the
night oh I ever wanted was to just give
the truth so the one Fe all through the
night fish on Thursday night wedn J
and through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth so the one timeat all
through
dance good enough to dance good enough
to dance good enough to dance kie loves
to
dancee loves to dance on the dance ball
because she is a camel and camels love
to dance when the feeling is
right in
time
love
[Music]
don't